I was really happy with the way that the
fight where the cave troll came out on
Fellowship of the Ring that's when they
are in this tomb and the Moria and is
this big troll and stabs Frodo I think
and the guys already try to kill him and
that was actually interesting because
that was like handheld there was us
doing on a CGI creature but doing it
with handheld cameras which I don't
think that have really been done before
so making it look were pretty grubby and
like a DOS tile handheld realism I was
really happy with the way that actually
ended up I mean it's not technically
that troll doesn't look as good as stuff
we can do now you know there's a but
just the I mean it certainly sticks in
my mind is something I was pretty proud
of at the time here being a storyboard
artist especially for Peter I you know I
learned a lot about visual storytelling
and in Lord of the Rings we translated
from storyboards into 3d previs so we
started you know actually turning what
I'd drawn into actual shots and
animating camera moves which then
defined how the shooting process went
we also found that you sometimes got to
location and you had a better idea
because of now you're actually looking
at the the set as it was built and you
might have a better camera angle and so
it's also you know a case of you know
have a plan but don't be afraid to throw
it away if you can think of something
better on the day and so it sort of more
those sort of almost you know those
high-level kind of philosophical ways of
working then then the actual technical
you know the the technical specifics and
a lot of technical things you need to
keep on top off but usually you defer
those to your visual effects supervisor
in your director of photography and you
know and you sort of you're just there
to be sort of keeping an eye on you know
making sure the performances are real
and making you know giving the actors
kind of to trust you and and making sure
that you know they're doing their best
work and that you're telling the story
in the most interesting way that you can
I would say that probably you know with
Lord of the Rings um the big advance and
CGI that would that movies was probably
Gotham you know and it wasn't it's not
just a computer part of Gollum it's the
whole thing it's a motion captured
character who's a real character whose
lips have to move and his face moves and
his eyes it look real and he has to
interact with the ground and you know
everywhere he go just a foot behind so I
know there was a lot of stuff with
golden that
had never been done before and um and we
you know we didn't know just with how
far we could actually go with it you
know we were sort of you know nervous
I'd say you know because if you actually
haven't got the software and you've got
this job to do you know you'd not even
quite sure that you can actually create
something that's gonna look any good and
there was certainly a period with God
and we didn't have Gollum really for the
first maybe the first little rings from
Fellowship of the Ring which comes in
about two shots and that golden is
completely different to the Gollum
that's in the next film that the two
towers the Fellowship of the Ring Gollum
is pretty gnarly pretty crude it was as
good as we could do at that time and we
had to have something in the movie but
we've remember and read deep shadow and
that was on purpose because he didn't
look very good but under lease we've ran
out of time and that was what we had to
have in the movie but we still have
another year to get him really good for
the two towers where he was a you know
half the film so that the two towers
Gollum which could complete overhaul you
know that that finally got got the place
what was interesting about the evolution
of Gollum was Golan was designed before
Andy Serkis was even cast and it was a
the design was fine it was like it was a
sort of you know it looked kind of what
you'd expect Gollum to look like it had
big eyes and green emaciated sort of
figure but then when we cast Andy and we
saw how wonderful his performance was it
just wasn't translating into the
animated character you know we weren't
able to get you know the characteristics
of his face and then Andy was cast as
Smeagol in the flashback and it was then
that I you know I actually just looked
and I thought okay this isn't working
and what I did is I took a photo of Andy
as Smeagol and I didn't got the
proportions of what our current Gollum
puppet was at winner and I did a pencil
sketch and I've got it somewhere but I
did a pencil sketch which was then going
okay if Andy you know if Andy had become
a summation figure in his eyes had got
slightly bigger what would that look
like and that sort of became Gollum and
it went through another design phase in
3d with a sculpture so we sort of drove
the performance to be based on Andy and
then when we got to when with a digital
went through the hoops and they remodel
the face and there was a shot it's wind
Frodo and Sam catch the rabbits and
they're talking about cooking the meat
and Gollum spits up and it was one shot
and we saw it and it was
we've nailed it I mean Gollum is always
you know he's described in the books and
everything it's a weed he's skinny sort
of coming climbing you know he's fairly
vividly described in it and a lot of the
illustrations over the years you know
they do and people that are very similar
sort of creature is not you know no one
really goes too wide so we can sudden
you what Gollum had to look like in
general terms okay now we just thought
that God would probably just be a voice
artist that we want yeah we didn't
really we hadn't put our brains into
this whole milk everything at all that
sage so Andy came in and I didn't know
who he wasn't he wasn't a familiar face
to me in any way and so he you know
audition like an actor sits in a chair
you know I I'm here and you can read the
lines and you know but Andy just jumped
on the furniture he he lips on the
chairs even on the floor he was coughing
out he's ecity bases up he based his
audition on I was kept coughing up fur
balls and he was leaving I mean he was
leaping over the backs of the chairs and
the tables of stuff we are flying and he
was doing all the physical the
physicality I mean I thought you know I
was kind of a bit taken back right from
this this guy is pretty over-the-top you
know but but then I could actually even
even at that moment I mean what Andy was
doing in his own clever way as he was
saying without saying it he was actually
saying guys you know I can give you a
performance you'd not just the voice I
can actually be Gollum and don't don't
you want me to be to actually excellent
nothing he was he was going to be no
because he knew I was gonna be CC CGI
but he was pitching without you know in
a subtle way he was pitching the whole
idea of you know you can use my
performance to drive your CGI character
and it was actually it was him doing all
that was the first time that with that
idea even it was someone that wonder
what one that we thought about and so we
we slowly Andy and whitter and I sweet
we slowly went through this period of
discovery realizing that actually if
Andy X column and we motion capture them
it's pretty good and then if Andy with
if we can figure out a way to capture
his face that's pretty good too so when
Andy moves his face around you notice
things Ghanim does the same thing and
then what happens is you actually get
them at we found we you get a much
better result if the face of the
creature is closest in structure to the
actors face you mean it doesn't have to
be but somehow
looks better if so we should redesign
golem to look a little bit like Andy
Serkis a sort of a colonized version of
any circus and it was done not to
flatter Andy I mean although you know
soon he deserves it but it was done
because you get bitter results if the
facial structure of your creature is
based on the actors general facial
structure and actually to did it the
same when he when because I'm Way too
did the Apes films I know you know they
went through the same thing on those
movies they made um Caesar that's
character that any plays they made him
look sort of Andy Serkis liked them as
well as it it gets you a bit of a bitter
result we couldn't for the Lord of the
Rings movies motion capture on the sit
with the actors it was going to do with
the lighting and the motion capture
cameras which you have around the thing
so in other words what then what that
means is that you'd have a scene with
Gollum and Frodo and Sam so you got
Elijah and Sean and Andy and we would
shoot the three of them in a location or
in a sit in the studio and Elijah and
Sean were obviously you know you know
acting the scene and we should venture
takes and their performance would be in
the film Andy was also performing and
yet none of what he did we could use not
one thing because we couldn't motion
capture him but he was there you know
performing it because obviously the
character of Gollum had to be very real
for them but poor old Andy what what
what happened is that the film would be
the shoot would be over Elijah and Sean
we go home two states and then Andy
would have to redo everything all over
again by himself in a motion-capture
stage you know when a properly set up
stage where the motion capture cameras
were done record so here to repeat
everything he'd done before you know
look looking at a screen with playback
and this time around who was actually
being his movements were getting
recorded and this might be I mean some
cases like eight months nine months
after he'd done it the first time around
everything had to be done twice which is
a bit so soulless ring you know in some
ways I mean he it was actually good and
one level because he was all of our
focus was just on him so we were able to
really kind of finesse it and then by
the time we did call him on the Hobbit
by that stage the technology just said
that we could motion capture on the sit
so in column and Nina Mountain Freeman
doing this scene together like you know
mountains being shot and Andy's being
motion capture all the same time so he
didn't have to do anything afterwards he
was all captured live on set if you
watch the monitor you see Martin Freeman
and
you see Gollum maybe you see like a sort
of slightly low res vision but it is it
is Gollum Andy Andy Hank there at all